la parole est à madame natacha bouchart
pour le groupe union pour un mouvement
populaire
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur jérôme
cahuzac ministre du budget
monsieur le ministre
alors que l'année 2013 s'annonce comme
la plus difficile pour nos compatriotes
confrontées à la crise l'heure devrait
être au rassemblement pour relever les
vrais défis de notre pays avant tout de
nature économique
les réformes sociétales que le
gouvernement met en place sont-elles la
priorité des français qui souffrent rien
n'est moins sûr
parmi les vrais sujets il y a le
financement des collectivités locales
il semblerait que les dotations versées
par l'état devrait être à nouveau
diminuer
la presse s'en est fait l'écho
un effort financier supplémentaire
considérable de 1 milliard et demi
d'euros d'ici à 2015 serait imposée pour
financer une partie du crédit d'impôt
compétitivité
soit un doublement du montant prévu par
la loi de la programmation que nous
venons de voter qui prévoyait 750
millions d'euros par an en
2014 et 2015
en tout ce seront 10 milliards d'euros
d'économies à trouver d'ici 2015 pour
financer ce crédit d'impôt
dispositif complexe dont l'efficacité
est mise en doute par les patrons des
pme
bien sûr les collectivités territoriales
doit participer à l'effort de
redressement des finances publiques
mais dans des justes proportions
mais nous n'en sommes plus là
est ce cela un pacte de confiance et de
solidarité conclu entre l'état et les
collectivités locales
la menace est brandie
du répercussions très forte sur le
fonctionnement des collectivités à
travers la facture du changement des
rythmes scolaires notamment
et sur les investissements en
particulier pour les communes
maire de calais ville de 75000 habitants
qui luttent face à la crise je suis
inquiète et je me fais le porte parole
de tous ces territoires qui souffrent
mais veulent s'en sortir et attendre
surtout d'être soutenu alors monsieur le
ministre puisque ce mot confiance et
votre argument dans vos relations avec
les collectivités
pouvez vous nous expliquer précisément
quelles sont les véritables intentions
du gouvernement en ce qui concerne la
dgf la dde la dsu et la prime
d'aménagement du territoire merci
monsieur jérôme cahuzac
ministre chargé du budget merci monsieur
le président madame la sénatrice je vous
confirme que le gouvernement a deux
priorités dans les politiques publiques
qu'ils mettent en oeuvre la première
c'est le redressement des comptes
publics et la deuxième c'est bien
évidemment restaurer la compétitivité de
nos entreprises dont on sait qu'elle
s'est effondrée ces dix dernières années
je vous rappelle que le déficit du
commerce extérieur en 2011 plus de 70
milliards d'euros et que ce commerce
extérieur était excédentaire encore en
2001 pour mettre en oeuvre la première
politique de redressement des finances
publiques vous savez l'effort que l'état
consent nous en avons abondamment
discuté dans cet hémicycle lors de
l'examen des lois de finances et il a
semblé légitime au gouvernement ainsi me
semble-t-il à une très grande majorité
d'élus locaux que les collectivités
locales contribuent à cet ajustement en
proportion naturellement de leur
responsabilité dans cet endettement vous
le savez l'endettement du pays est en
gros de 1700 milliards d'euros l'état
est responsable pour 80% de cet
endettement les collectivités locales et
la protection sociale de 10 % pour
chacune de ces deux administrations et
donc demander un effort aux
collectivités locales correspondant à
10% de l'effort global paraît juste et
légitime j'en veux pour preuve
d'ailleurs que bien peu d'élus locaux ou
qu'ils siègent sur ses bancs née
protester contre ce qui fut annoncée par
mes soins au comité des finances locales
c'est-à-dire un effort de 750 millions
d'euros en 2014 et 750 millions d'euros
supplémentaires en 2015 par rapport à
2013 soit un effort au total et sur
trois ans de 2 milliards 250 millions
d'euros quand le budget des
collectivités locales chaque année
madame la sénatrice vous le savez est de
220 milliards d'euros cet effort est
juste parce qu'il est en proportion de
la responsabilité des collectivités
locales dans l'endettement du pays et
puis la deuxième priorité c'est le
rétablissement de la compétitivité de
nos entreprises le crédit impôt
compétitivité emploi nécessite de
dégager une dizaine de milliards d'euros
d'économies et il est envisagé son
qu'aucune décision ne soit prise pour
l'instant il est envisagé de demander
aux collectivités de participer à cet
effort tant il est vrai que tous les
territoires bénéficieront des progrès de
compétitivité que les entreprises
pourrait réaliser par la richesse créée
par l'emploi créé par l'investissement
créé bref par la vitalité soit confortée
soit rétabli dans chacun des territoires
de notre pays l'annoncé devrait en être
faite le cas échéant au comité des
finances locales vous savez que celle
usage au demeurant je ne peux vous
annoncer quoi que ce soit aujourd'hui
dans la mesure où aucune décision n'est
prise en revanche je peux vous dire ce
que le gouvernement par ma voix ni par
la voix de madame lebranchu que je salue
ni par celle de mav escoffier que je
salue également
je peux vous dire que lors de ce comité
des finances locales le gouvernement
n'annoncera pas il n'annoncera pas ceux
qui étaient dans le programme de l'ump
des élections législatives c'est à dire
un effort de 10 milliards d'euros
demandés aux collectivités locales
cet effort nous avons toujours considéré
qu'il était tout à fait excessif et
déraisonnable
je vous vois protesté madame la
sénatrice et je le comprends car c'est
probablement la mort dans l'âme si vous
aviez gagné ces élections que vous
auriez accepté les décisions du
gouvernement que vous auriez soutenue de
demander 10 milliards d'euros aux
collectivités locales un effort tout à
fait insupportable que celle ci n'aurait
pu évidemment assumer sans augmenter les
impôts de nos compatriotes chose à
laquelle j'en suis certain vous seriez
refusé voilà donc près d'am la
scénariste que je voulais vous apporter
comme précision je ne vous avez ce que
le gouvernement n'annoncera pas et je
vous donne rendez vous la semaine
prochaine pour préciser ce que serait la
part des collectivités locales pour
restaurer compétitivité des industries
fut bien mise à mal par les politiques
publiques menées ces dix dernières
années